[Music]
all those present
in the chamber as well as members and
staff throughout the capital
and all who love john lewis wherever you
are
rise in a moment of silence and
remembrance of the contents of the
congress
the honorable john lewis
the honorable john lewis indeed an
emotional moment on capitol hill
yesterday
as the lawmakers honored the life and
legacy of the great john lewis known as
the conscience of congress as you heard
nancy pelosi say
before his more than three decades in
congress lewis served as an atlanta
council member
alongside future mayor that's bill
campbell
the two became lifelong friends and only
on cbs this morning
bill campbell joins us now from atlanta
to talk about the civil rights icon
good morning to you mr mayor i'm so
sorry it's under these circumstances but
i really appreciate you taking the time
thank you for having me
we were thinking about listen the
country has lost a
hero they've lost a leader but you have
lost a friend
you called him your nearest and dearest
as a matter of fact and i know that you
got to spend time with him
during these final moments can you talk
to us about your final visits
john's diagnosis with stage four
pancreatic cancer
we we both knew that it was a death
sentence it disproportionately affects
african americans
my mother died of it and so i visited
john
a number of times in the last week
before his
uh his death it was striking that the
last conversations that we had
were about his commitment to voting he
was so
concerned that the country vote in
november in fact his last
cogent words to me were this is the most
important election
of our lifetime and we must all go and
vote and i think that speaks about
what he considered to be fundamental and
important and what he spent his entire
life fighting for
yeah but you had a touching moment i was
reading that you two talked you embraced
you kissed him on his forehead
well i thought that was so sweet
john has been one of the most important
figures in history but also
one of the most meaningful people that
i've ever met
in my life and these moments where we
spent
at the very end of his life or were so
important for me i wanted to express my
appreciation and my love for this
this great man but also to tell him how
much he had meant to me and
its death was imminent we both knew that
um but we somehow found peace in
in his transition in knowing what he had
meant to america
and what he meant to me and my family
such an extraordinary man who
rose from such humble roots abject
poverty
in rural alabama and yet he rose to be
one of the most powerful and beloved
figures in the 20th century it's a great
story for
everyone who doubts whether they can
achieve
and wants to overcome it they always
under appreciate it
and and and i think never really gave
john his his due because he was such a
small
unassuming man but what a powerful
impact he had on our lives
that's what i feel too that he was so
that i wonder if he knew how much people
loved and cared about him i wonder if he
was able
to take all of that in do you think he
was
gayle i'm certain that he was i spent a
lot of time with john
in different places around the country
and everywhere
john lewis went without bodyguards
without staff
people flocked to him and it was so
heartwarming for me
because i knew what he had done in his
life
and and it just it was so wonderful to
see people
touch him and love him and express that
to him
and uh it was just i think the most
remarkable journey of john's life and
his life story
you know i've said often and it's not
hyperbole uh gail
that um when i met john lewis as a young
lawyer
from duke um your son's alma mater
i thought it was a transcendent
experience it was like
meeting the great figures of history uh
thomas jefferson
benjamin franklin the the people that
wrote the declaration of independence
and
here i was meeting someone who had made
america bend and and live up to those
noble words john
lewis ct vivian another lion that we
just lost or
or andy young dr king it was uh
it was a remarkable life and i was
privileged to be able to to live
alongside of him
you know what struck me too about him
you know i called to check on him last
weekend oprah and i did and
and michael said you know you all should
talk to him he'd love to talk to you on
the phone we're like no no no we can't
and we talked him on the phone last
saturday and oprah was saying you've
been such a blessing in my life
and he said to her no oprah you've been
a blessing in mind and we both just had
a moment with that because
even at the end bill even at the end
he's thinking about others
and trying to uplift others i just
thought that was so extraordinary
well think about this gail john
used his last public appearance in life
to go and stand in the black lives
matter plaza
he had been told that the cancer had
ravaged his body
he did not have long to live and yet he
was able to get
up and go and stand in that plaza
to express to the young people of
america how powerful their voices had
been
and the changes that they had made in
america which he had fought for
his entire life and i i think when you
when you look at john's life and his
life arc
and you see that it was always about
making america better
he had this incorruptible integrity like
a halo
and it just made all of us better who
knew him
and your your phone call and oprah's
phone call and
and uh speaker pelosi and president
obama and vice president biden
the winans saying to john uh
over the phone it just made his uh his
last moment
special yes and we keep hearing that he
loves
hillary clinton was saying we all know
that he was joyful
he loved the song happy by pharrell you
two must have had some playful moments
that were unique to just the two of you
do you have an antidote about that yes
of course we
first of all you know we shared an
office for uh for five years then we
gotta go
yes john lewis only learned to drive in
his seventies
and the first time he wanted to show me
that he could drive
he ran through a stop sign and i said
john what happened he said oh i didn't
even recognize
it was there so he was just such a
wonderful human being to be around
and we will miss him a great deal
we really will he made us all so happy
we thank you mayor bill campbell for
joining us really good to see you i'm
sorry it's this way